FiFierté, pour les commerçantsts
icici, c'est un peu comme le Grd
PrPrix pour les gens de la rue
PePeel.
- - La déceptionon demeure vive
popour ce tenancier de bar
dadans le e Village. L'annulatin
enen catastrophe du défilé de
lala Fierté a été un coup dur pr
seses ventes. L'achalandage qu'l
ananticipait a été bien moindre.
PAPASCAL LEFEBVRE
prpropriétaire du bar Normandie
- - L'année dernière, il y avait
eueu une marche quand même, même
s's'il n'y avait pas eu de para,
etet la marche s'était terminée
dadans le Village, sur la rue
AtAtateken, et ça avait amené
bebeaucoup de gens à circuler ds
lele Village. Donc on n'a pas eu
cecette manne-là.
- - Un sentiment partagé par
cecet employé d'un établissement
vovoisin.
ALALAIN GARCEAU
ememployé du bar Le Rockyy
- - On a eu moins de monde que
prprévu. C'est sûr que c'est
plplate. Pourtant, ils se
prpréparent depuis un an!
- - Malgré cette bourde,
lele directeur général de Fierté
MoMontréal a l'intention de
dedemeurer en poste.
SISIMON GAMACHE, directeur génél
dede Fierté Montréal
- - Présentement, non, moi,
jeje ne songe pas à démissionne.
PrPrésentement, je suis là, mais
papar contre, regardez, j'ai des
papatrons et des patronnes, c'et
unun conseil d'administration et
cece sera à eux de décider quoi
fafaire avec m moi.
- - C'est une erreur
adadministrative qui a forcé
l'l'annulation de l'événement.
DeDes dizaines d'agents d'accuel
emembauchés pour le festival n't
papas été affectés à la sécurité
dudu défilé.
FRFRANÇOIS LEGAULT
prpremier ministre du Québec
- - C'est pas la faute de la Vie
dede MTL, c'est pas la faute des
popoliciers, c'est pas la faute
dudu gouvernement du Québec.
IlIl y a eu une erreur de
l'l'organisation puis c'est
mamalheureux.
- - Des organismes qui travaillt
avavec Fierté Montréal souhaitet
unune reddition de compte.
ALALEXANDRE DUMONT BLAIS,
didirecteur général de RÉZO
- - On va laisser l'organisation
fafaire son post-mortem pour
s's'assurer évidemment que ça
sese reproduise pas.
- - Au lendemain de ce fiasco,
l'l'incompréhension chez
leles festivaliers persiste.
- - Je ne suis pas vraiment fier
cecette année de la tournure des
évévénements, honnêtement.
- - C'était décevant, mais le
momonde s'arrange tout le temps.
JeJe te dirais, la communauté,
pepeu importe ce qui arrivive,
çaça se rassemble e et puis ça .
- - Un comomité a été mis en ple
popour f faire la lumière sur ci
s's'esest passé. En fin de jour,
leles s organisateurs ont rencoé
lala mairesse, Valérie Plante,
popour qui, comme plusieurs, de
nonombreuses questions demeurent
enentières.
I Ici Aimée Lemie